would you want to know the day you're
going to die or no
no no absolutely absolutely you would
absolutely you would want to know 100 i
got the psychic for two thousand dollars
she'll tell you you know why i got the
hit man it was
why not this is a cia operative let's
hear your response to this yeah so uh
but by the way everybody listen to this
i'm curious comment as well would you
want to know the day
you're going to die it would change
every decision that you would make
if you if you knew
you would uh you would make sacrifices
that you wouldn't otherwise make and you
would you would no longer be playing the
long game because you would you would
now be in a zero-sum game
so you know i mean the perspective yeah
the most successful people that that i
know you talk about this on your uh on
your podcasts and in your social media a
lot right you mean you've got to play
the long game
you're playing chess not checkers
and if you knew the day that you were
going to die i mean we're not even
talking a minute you just knew the day
you were going to die
you just entered a checkers game and at
that point like
why why why plan beyond that point right
so why do you say that it's a checkers
game knowing the damn you're gonna die
because you're you're you're no longer
by not knowing so
uh i think elon musk said that if you if
you give yourself 30 days to clean your
house thirty years it'll take 30 days if
you give yourself three hours it'll take
three hours
you don't know if you're going to get
hit by a car this afternoon and so you
play the game
most people i think most successful
people play the game as if they are
going to get hit by a car this afternoon
so you try to pack in as much as they
can as much life as much
as much value as they can in a shorter
period of time as they can and that that
leads to
somebody like elon musk creating
freaking you know car companies that
that outperformed gm and trying to
colonize mars simultaneously right i'm
trying to fight human trafficking and
fraud simultaneously if i knew that i
had another
70 years
i would probably slow down is that a
good thing nick i disagree with you
completely yeah 100 i think that you're
a high functioning individual and you're
making a classic mistake a lot of people
would disagree with that
[Music]
i've seen people in my life and my
family wake up every day sit in traffic
they don't want to sit in to go to a job
that they don't want to do
because they need to accumulate wealth
for a life that they don't really live
so if they knew that they had
eight years left do you think they're
sitting in an hour and a half traffic
going through the lincoln tunnel to go
work a job that they don't want to do or
do you think that they're finally
getting their ass out going to europe
seeing what they want to see doing what
they want to do
you know we get caught up in an
accumulation game but you never nobody
here has ever seen
a tombstone with a net worth on it
so if you knew your days were numbered
you'd start checking things off the
bucket list immediately i can offer some
interesting perspective on that because
so
uh my career started right straight in
the military straight into special ops
uh lost my two best friends six months
after we graduated pj school like i
didn't think i would make it to 25. now
i made it to 25 and i was like well
there's no way i'm gonna make it to 30
because none of my friends did then i
made it to 30 and then i was like
well 40 like there there's no possible
way that's gonna happen because none of
my friends did because you were the
cocaine poodle yeah pretty much are you
40 yet or no yeah i'm 43 now okay and so
you know so then i was like all right
you know late 30s got married i've got
two toddlers now right i mean so so i
guess just kind of playing a a
i guess who you would say a pretty fast
and loose game in combat
uh and doing some really dangerous stuff
in in my teens and and twenties i mean
you can make an argument that most
special operators are like are
borderline suicidal uh with the stuff
that we do
in i had to come to uh i had to come to
terms with my own death pretty darn fast
there's a certain amount of freedom in
that though there's a there's nothing
but freedom in that okay explain that to
me because you're 21 you're thinking i'm
not making it to 25. you're 25 you think
i'm not making it to 30. 34. pat talks
about 20-year runs right
first 20 years don't do anything stupid
next 20 years make your money
you know the 20 years after that work on
what you want to be doing right and then
your last 40
to 20 years give back did i summarize it
okay but you you thought you'd be dead
by 25 30. what the hell is that mindset
how do you walk me through why that's
freedom or liberating
it's liberating
depending on what your currency is right
so everybody's got a different currency
right uh my my currency is impact like i
am going to reduce human trafficking by
globally by 80 by the time i die i'm
going to i'm going to drive a billion
dollars into the fight against human
trafficking by 2040.
i got 18 years left on that um but
but that's the impact that i'm having
now the impact i was having then you
know over my my time in pararescue you
know there's 27 people that got to go
home to their that got to go home to
their families because of the impact
that i had
uh
in that time so it all depends i think
of what your what your currency is if if
the currency is well i just i'm going to
sit in this traffic because i want to
make sure that my kids
can go to college and i want to pay for
it i want to say it's 100 noble and
dutiful to do that absolutely but i
think there's a difference between a
culture of accumulation which i fully
agree that we are we are eyeballs deep
in a culture of accumulation um
there's a difference between that
and then also having a a
a culture outside of self where you're
thinking about your kids and that's why
you're willing to sit in that traffic so
i think it all depends on are you
willing to sit in the traffic just
because you're trying to get the get the
thing for yourself or are you sitting in
the traffic because you're trying to
you know you're trying to lift your your
family up generationally and i think we
have so many you look at the immigrant
community in this country you have so
many immigrants who come into this
country
and fathers and mothers who will kill
themselves
with work
so that their children can go to college
and live the american dream so i think
it all depends on the reason why i think
i think what you said made so much sense
that it has to do with currency there's
two things that gerard that you
contradicted yourself and i want to kind
of highlight this because of what you
made one very good point
uh when you said sagitt's legacy is
gonna live on right so the currency of
that is what legacy is going to live on
which means we want to figure out a way
to live forever right if you got eight
years to live
you're gonna probably sit there and
go through all the stuff you wanna do um
you know i'm gonna go see this i'm gonna
go party here i'm gonna try this i'm
gonna try that i'm gonna try and be like
dude this [ __ ] is boring as hell the
hell is this all about then you're gonna
say what am i gonna do for me to put a
you know leave a legacy behind the
famous jewish proverb i don't know if
it's a proverb or a saying
is there's three the things every man
should do you know the one is plan to
treat second one is uh have a son third
one is write a book each one of those
things is about what something outliving
you right like you want something to
outlive you
uh uh so i don't know i don't know if
i'd want to know when i'm dying i don't
know if i'd want to know if i'm dying
what would you want to know on your diet
time would you want to know the day
you're dying i'm i'm comfortable every
day yeah i'm comfortable every day at
this it comes from from my faith which
is really really bingo and so i i
believe that
god's numbered my days and i'm just not
here to be foolish with them i don't
walk in front of trucks and say i wonder
if today is my day and god's gonna
mysteriously
holy spirit's going to sweep me away
from the front of that truck no my
my faith is also based on impact uh
that's why at the end of all my case
studies they say my name is tom
ellsworth is not going to hope i left
you better than i found you yeah i just
that's my impact i want to teach and
lead people better than i found them and
so with my faith i'm very very
comfortable with it um i came face to
face with that a little bit you know
this summer you know with um with covid
wondering why i was one of the one
percent that delta heard that i'm
sitting there in icu and i got delta and
i don't have diabetes and i'm my
you know all the other markers i have no
comorbidities i'm not heavy i mean all
the things were there i'm like okay lord
is this the way it's gonna be and okay
and i sent a lot of emails to a lot of
people and did a lot of thing in that
day and i also think about what you're
asking that's me but i'm going to say
let's look at a real life example um you
remember randy pouch who is the
professor at carnegie mellon university
and uh last lectures it was called
when you know it's an amazing thing pat
when you know
most people turn to impact when randy
knew he knew his cancer was stage three
he said look this is where it's going to
go so he said i'm going to use as much
of my time as i'm physically able to
teach and to talk and he did this whole
series called last lectures which is
tremendous and it was captured also a
little bit
um in the book tuesdays with maury yeah
mitch album correct great book great
book yeah
so i think when people face it they
usually turn to impact and you they
don't turn to partying and seeing all
the places on earth because at the end
of the day that's kind of meaningless
did i see everything so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]